irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
amérique du sud côte pacifique p o
au delà du grand a dit plano vivent les
descendants des sujets du grand un cas
les couettes choissent autrefois m
d'aliments sains voici au fond d'un
vallon l'une de ces fermes cossu entouré
de huttes misérable habité par de riches
propriétaires terriens qui maintiennent
les indiens dans un état proche du
servage les rocheuses agricoles des
andes sont peu nombreuses
la plus pittoresque est l'une des plus
importantes et l'élevage de l'alpaga
ulama porteurs de l'aisne ces animaux
sont à moitié sauvage et lorsque une
fois l'an on les rassemble pour la tonte
le seul moyen de les capturer et de les
attraper au lasso
à cette occasion les indiens rivalisent
adresse ce nouveau de véritables scènes
de rodéo
comme tous les peuples pauvres les
indiens sont principalement végétarien
mais il profite de l'époque de la tente
pour choisir les bêtes les plus âgés les
abattre y consommer leur viande c'est
pratiquement la seule que mangent ces
indiens
il
il faut bien céder on ne peut tout de
même pas faire un étrangleur voilà
m
plus d'étudier la plus grands tubes
le centre du village effet de maisons en
pis les parfois plutôt délabré mais on y
trouve une église saint pée charmante
car si extraordinaire que cela puisse
paraître certains jours cette contrée
est profondément catholique sur la place
une vieille fontaine distribuer l'eau
potable à la population
celle ci est composée la population bien
sûr d'un mélange de pur indien et de
métis d'aspect tout aussi misérable il
est d'ailleurs parfois c'est difficile
de distinguer des indiens des métis on
reconnaît ceux ci à ce qu'il porte des
loques d'origine industrielle alors que
les véritables indien tout au moins les
quetsches masse n'utilise pratiquement
que des vêtements entièrement fabriquée
à la main d'après de très anciennes
techniques artisanales ses vêtements
diffère un peu selon les vallées mais
ont toujours des traits communs
c'est ainsi que les femmes portent une
série de jupes superposées les unes au
dessus les autres ses jupes laisse voir
le genou
plus le nombre de jupe est important
plus large une personne est supposé
avoir de fortune donc bien entendu puis
j'ai la chance de trouver un mari l'a
pas plus qu'ailleurs l'human et
désintéressé ses vêtements sont
entièrement fabriqués à la main selon
des traditions remontant à l'époque un
caïques la laine de mouton ou alpagas et
d'abord fille née à la main
voilà le geste
les peuples précolombien a été
extraordinaire qui seront les étoffes
que l'on a trouvé dans certaines tombes
sont remarquables par la finesse de
leurs textures et l'art de leurs dessins
une partie de ces traditions se sont
perdus mais aujourd'hui encore les
indiens savent produire de très très
belles étoffes les filles de l'aisne
obtenu par un long travail manuel sont
ensuite hissé sur des métiers d'aspect
très très primitif jugez vous même mais
les tissus qui en sortent eux sont de
véritables petites merveilles
ce travail est extrêmement lent ce qui
explique peut-être que cette misérable
n'ai pas vécu dans ces hautes vallées la
mortalité infantile est épouvantable
dans la ferme ont été tournées ces
images le propriétaire avouer que 7 sur
10 des enfants meurent entre la
naissance et la fin de leur première
année
cette mortalité est due à l'usagé
excessive d'alcool de basse qualité et
l'effet toxique de la coca et aussi à
totalement d'hygiène en effet les
indiennes se lave jamais et leurs huttes
sont plus que sordide
les couettes chasse on garde est
d'ailleurs fort peu de choses de leur
ancienne civilisation quelques
techniques artisanales et le goût du
travail en commun c'est ainsi que nous
pouvons assister au battage de la
moisson par une connectivité d'indiens
pour battre le grain pour le détacher de
la paille les indiens ne connaissent pas
votre méthode que celle que leur ont
enseigné des premiers conquistadors
elle consiste à fear piétiner la moisson
par un troupeau de chevaux tournoyant en
rond au centre d'un cercle d'hommes les
excitants par des criques et les
gesticulations lorsque la paille a été
longtemps piétiné un premier groupe de
travailleurs comment ça vanne et le
grain ainsi obtenu en le jetant dans le
vent
à
de fait
et
voilà la seconde opération
mais afin qu aucune parcelle de ces
précieuses grain risquent d'être perdus
d'autres hommes push la paille
un peu plus loin pour la fiac kittin et
une seconde fois
voilà la troisième opération
et à celle ci succède le vannage
définitif
le vent emporte loin l'appareil plus
légère et seul le beau george tombe au
sol
le travail est fait avec le plus grand
soin est pratiquement pas une seule
graine les perdu en une journée de ce
labeur aux méthodes primitives
les indiens ont tout de même réussi à
produire trois tonnes de grains d'or le
travail a duré toute la journée et les
hommes vont chercher injuste repos
ce repos ils le prendront hélas en
buvant de l'arcadia n'tait et en chic en
la côte cassée deux grands poison du
pérou principaux responsables de la
décadence de la race indienne
e
plus tard les camions de l'hacienda
emporteront vers les grandes villes de
la côte l'orge des indiens et après la
moisson la grande ferme retrouvera pour
quelques semaines le rythme lent de son
existence habituelle elle ne s'animera à
nouveau que pour la récolte des pommes
de terre que nous voyons pratiqué ici
dans une autre vallée 200 km plus au
nord les indigènes de cette région porte
de curieux costumes voulant imiter ce
les fonctionnaires espagnols de l'époque
coloniale
ils les gardent en toutes circonstances
et même pour travailler ce qui leur
confère une dignité parfaite
vous n'ignorez pas que la pomme de terre
est originaire du pérou mais c'est sans
doute dans leur parti d'origine que ces
tubercules sont le plus mal cultiver le
rendement y est de ce fait
incroyablement pas
agréé gosses
autrement dit un blanc est passée par là
et il a donné des bonbons à ses petits
enfants hélas l'un d'entre eux a été
perdu et c'est vraiment pour eux un
drame il le cherche il le cherche
je vous attends ils se trouvent
après le travail à la fête
c'est une simple fête villageoise à
laquelle ne participait une trentaine
d'indiens tous devraient quetchua ce
descendant direct du peuple qui sut
bâtir l'empiré inca
seuls les musiciens sont des métis venue
des basses vallées
la fête commence gentiment on danse on
mange on boit l'ensemble dans une
sympathique ambiance champêtre
malheureusement comme toujours cela
dégénère rapidement en une orgie
abominable
ces indiens sont honnêtes travailleurs
hospitaliers
il suffirait peut-être de peu de choses
pour faire 2-1 peuple exemplaires
probablement un léger travail
d'éducation
oh
non
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec leonel terrain tom de boy
et solange péters montage pierre michel
rey script lucette ambri sont à nick v
dit claude gilles son illustration
sonore dominic palladini